alemania ha estado parcialmente
confinada durante las últimas seis
semanas con bares y restaurantes
cerrados algunos lugares han sido
criticados por montar puestos de comida
de temporada para llevar no nadie se
hará rico vendiendo 3 o 4 litros de vino
caliente por supuesto que vemos caras
nuevas y lo importante para nosotros es
mantener el contacto con nuestra base de
clientes y también poder pagar el
alquiler
superbrands
pero los dueños de negocios se enfrentan
ahora a medidas de cierre más estrictas
con las tiendas cerradas a partir de
mediados de la próxima semana y hasta el
10 de enero la canciller angela merkel
dijo que las reglas actuales ya no son
suficientes discuto el endurecimiento de
las restricciones este domingo durante
una videoconferencia con los líderes de
los 16 estados de alemania las
autoridades locales habían acordado un
plan para permitir que el cierre se
suavizará en navidad' pero algunas
regiones han impuesto desde entonces
medidas más duras incluyendo baviera y
el estado suroccidental de
baden-württemberg donde se han
establecido toques de queda nocturnos
alemania fue elogiada internacionalmente
por su éxito en mantener la pandemia
bajo control a principios de este año
pero ha sido golpeada duramente por una
segunda ola del virus con nuevas
infecciones superando hasta en tres
veces el pico de la primavera algunos
ministros advierten que las unidades de
cuidados intensivos se están colapsando
y que el país no puede esperar hasta
después de navidad para actuar
el número de casos confirmados de kobe
19 aumentó en más de 20.000 este domingo
para alcanzar más de 13 millones y casi
22 mil personas han muerto